hey what's up everybody Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this episode of
rank of Fame we're gonna be talking
about I'm totally not upset about Serbia
losing in the World Cup and the group
stage is no big deal guys no big deal
actually we're gonna be discussing
previewing the anime of 2018 the new
anime coming up in the 2018 summer
season a lot of really interesting
animes so that's gonna be good
joining me we have Briggs from all day
animate this time I linked both his
channel and his twitch in the desert a
legend first time ever that I remembered
to put your twitch and we also got novel
got up back in the house her channel is
also linked in the description my twitch
actually your YouTube I don't know what
you do oh if I were you - oh yeah we're
all making a swap no I am no I mean yeah
oh god this is hard
[Laughter]
existence is difficult like your YouTube
chocolate that's why I always did before
but if you have a twitch or something
you I can always do it later after the
stream just private message me we also
had invited anime recon to be here today
but something came up last minute and
also Jojo talks too much I asked him as
well but he was busy which happens you
know so it's gonna be us three today
also NOx Taku is not here this week guys
I was like naqshi common he's like I
don't give a [ __ ] about my fans gonna be
there [ __ ] you all know you had
something come up but suicide I thought
I ran cafe without nuts
you think he's a great guy but I got
Noah goddess I can just one piece it up
with her yeah I don't want peace ok one
piece is not part of the [ __ ] summer
see dude I'm looking at this right now
and I see water I see water he granblue
oh man line anyway welcome r1 in the
chat I see a bunch of people in the chat
already including Shura Prince a regular
ear at the rant
cafe could you have you my friend I have
actual coffee that's not not alcohol
that's great
[ __ ] happens yeah so we have a lot of
interesting stuff going by the way I'm
I'm probably the worst person to talk
about like what's upcoming into summer
season because I still have like three
anime that I need to be watching from
this season that I haven't been kept up
on that I am pissed off about not
keeping up with so I need to still be
watching those but we do have a new
season coming so this new season has a
lot of sequels and some high-profile new
animate the sequel is just like right
away that you see is we have overlord
season 3 apparently which I am surprised
that it's coming out so soon right yeah
Matt Ellis is actually making sequels
what are they doing yeah because
overlord season 2 came out in January
right you know yeah I think so
pretty nice it might have been sooner
maybe I don't know I felt like it was
really soon though it does feel like it
was like one after right another yeah so
basically they had the winter season
spring season no and then summer season
already season three so that's cool I
mean I like overlord so I'm a fan so
that's I'm just thing he's just
surprised I usually don't like I didn't
give overlord enough of a chance like I
watch the episodes I'm just like she has
no challenge he's so Overlord powered I
don't need to give it a chance I need to
try it because it's like yeah he's
overpowered but he also has to like live
in a world where he doesn't know what
other powers exist and he's trying to
like you know the Estates meant
essentially in control a kingdom oh it's
like there's politics there's strategy I
really do enjoy oh for sure sometimes I
would say there's a bit too much focus
on side characters however overall I
enjoy overlord
so yeah interesting that season 3 is
coming already I'd since I am a fan I
should make some videos on overlord I
still I don't think I have yeah you
probably should because it's kind of
like on the same niche of like in your
in the earth and your thing and your
niche it seems like one of your niches
like you're not your things my niche
Amin anime like yeah but you stick it
seems like you stick towards like more
of like what people want though you know
what I mean
like what your channel it's like what
people will are a blonde yeah you know
sometimes people analyze like older
stuff you know what I mean or you know
you know what I mean sometimes it works
right like going for it all the shrill
like it's such if you already have a
little bit of an audience but like yeah
that's like we only have so much time so
like at the time that we do have I think
we put towards series that we know like
people at least want yeah find that you
also like obviously like you exactly it
is going to school I can't stand Tokyo
sorry but the thing is that also I have
made analytical videos before they
usually don't get many views what I do
enjoy them and I do make them sometimes
yeah well yeah like in terms of like
Overlord I never tried making video I
don't know maybe people would enjoy and
maybe they'd like I don't care I don't
know we'll see I'll try one of these
days one of these days we also have a
bunch of other really interesting
sequels so we have fully Cooley
progressive that is the second season of
fooly cooly I watched the first episode
already I haven't watched the rest but
I'm definitely gonna make a video on
this because I made a video last year
about the original fooly cooly where I
talked about why I loved it and all the
hidden meaning within and and the
message yeah that video was very slow
but now I think it has over like 50,000
views it ended up doing well in the long
run so I'm definitely excited to do what
I've like an analysis sort of video on
the second season once it's done airing
its in the six episodes right the first
season is six episode the second so I
would definitely encourage you guys to
check it out it's not a big commitment
in terms of time or anything like that
yeah I really need him it's so worth it
and you can kill it in one night it's
just so damn good I'm surprised you
started off with overload and fooly
cooly and not attack on titan yeah
because I'm waiting I'm purposely
waiting people in the chat freaking out
like guys attack on Titan season 3 is
coming I was like probably why are they
not talking about that now and I'm just
I'm just kind of teasing you guys I
imagine I don't know what they're
talking about saying Oh a target on is
trash no it isn't you have no arguments
yeah patrol and I mean it's alright the
characters are kind of bland in my
opinion but the story's great
well yes so I don't think the characters
are bland but it is more plot driven
than or world driven than character
driven on again if you only want
character driven you might as well just
watch slice-of-life
yeah it's true I like a good combination
of both like ice I feel like you like
Eren Jaeger and because of that probably
ten times better for you but because I
just didn't like him that much it's hard
for me to get into it I still think it's
amazing I thought season two was [ __ ]
unbelievable season one I was on the
height for a little bit and I kind of
like lost interest towards the end but
student II was amazing yes I see someone
near the middle it gets slow because it
starts like running out of the manga
yeah but then season two because we had
to wait so long for season 2 it ended up
being very fast paced because they
didn't have to worry about not having
longer material no way we're gonna say
something I said I need to finish season
- I feel bad because I'm like like right
at the part where the the the talking
Titan appears I'm like right there how
did you stop there I don't even like I
was watching it with my buddy when he
was over visiting here like we were
watching it together I'm pretty sure her
who's either right before he came over
here and I was supposed to finish it
with them and I never did I haven't
finished it yet yeah I had done [ __ ] I
thought that when I watch where I watch
an MIT with someone yeah because I start
with someone I don't end up finishing it
but yeah you can't count on other people
no I just needed go in and finish it
myself there's quite a few series that
I'm actually really excited for just new
series that are coming out well that's
great cuz I have no idea what's coming
out there there's so many good ones - I
have to question - adamak before you
move on from attack on Titan having read
the long that when you say season three
has a lot of potential oh yes oh yeah
depends how far the season 3 is going to
go but I absolutely loved attack on
Titan manga and it just gets better in
this season like this season if it's
gonna be a full like 25 episode season
you're going to learn a lot about the
world that you haven't that you didn't
know before
alright the short season you will
a lot but it's gonna be like this is
gonna open everything up like only a lot
of these mysteries that we've been
wondering about the basement all this
type of stuff is going to be covered if
it's a full season so it's gonna be
crazy and I absolutely love it and like
these twists and things that you have to
really invest and wait for is why I love
the show
I love the storytelling I love how it
comes together like I know some people
don't because they don't appreciate
greatness but unhurt it's interesting
because Briggs for example you love one
piece Nala does too
but I've seen a lot of people in my
comments and stuffs just say the luffy's
a bland shitty character that he's
cliche do I'm not saying I'm not saying
that's right I know people have made
that argument to do he's like
simplistically perfect I like I'm making
a video I actually have a script written
about this already Ivan's like kind of
not really doing much one piece of
content but I'm kinda I'm gonna like
start going for it now just kind of to
see you so much I don't know why I
haven't like tried it just all out my
first video is titled why Luffy is
simplistically really and okay so it's
gonna be it's me great okay so that's a
little knock stock with type title oh
yeah oh yeah well I mean I'd look
forward to watching that because yeah I
think I mean characters can be simple
and awesome at the same time and they
could you can have complex characters
that are awesome as well so it's all
about the execution I thought well he's
this really one-dimensional he wants
something he goes and gets it he wants
to do something like he's going to do it
regardless of anything I think it just
fits like the picture of a pirate
perfectly I think it picks like sets up
the world perfectly I'm gonna go into
detail with the video but like some
random a where's he food away and how he
has to do it like how he has to
accomplish it like the crab that he has
to go through it just makes them perfect
yeah yeah um I don't know like I'm going
through the my anime list page for the
season and I'm finding a lot of like
just my way looking [ __ ] that I'm not
interested in oh my god no there's
really really good okay
though are you talking about like look
at this very long Japanese title but I
do know the English title is how to not
summon a demon lord no I'm talking about
I'm talking about think one room second
season like just I don't know what that
is
anything called two room image I can
tell it looks like a did you bro anime
find this right now because I mean that
did you probe would make a video saying
why it's brilliant immoral idiots for
not realizing it would you scroll all
the way down where do you see what one
room second season yeah I ask you don't
even see it well that's a sequel oh yeah
I think didn't know Aki didn't make a
video about that did she somebody made a
video about that on how stupid the video
or both anime was or there was like a
weird concept behind it somebody
mentioned it in a video it was an EU - I
don't know who it was
yeah I don't know all the anime me
tubers just blend together probably
could at the summer anime list I'm
seeing like four things in a row on the
left hand side like I guess you'd be
excited for bananafish yeah you should
be excited for bananafish I'm telling
you so about bananafish I don't know
anything about it other than if the
title is definitely a reference to a JD
Salinger short story and JD Salinger is
the guy who wrote Catcher in the Rye and
is referenced in ghost in the shell as
well the Laughing Man so I'm excited to
see how why they're referencing Salinger
like I like literature and reading a lot
so I'm excited to see now I'll sell this
to us why is this good you should watch
the UM trailer if you watch the trailer
you'll definitely get the vibe of like
to kind of get the vibe of what it just
of what it's about but it's it looks
really good really oh you read them on
or anything or you just haven't read the
manga um just watch the juice would be
wholly brought just off the synopsis off
the previews it looks damn good killer
I'm on board another one a really
excited for a series seriously Jaeger
that one looks really really really good
- you got to watch the previous to that
because I actually have like a lot of
english subtitling already for the
previews and that looks so good bro
Aaron is the only Jaeger I care about
this is I think the Jaeger is a town
like when you watch the preview I think
it's the area they're in or something it
might be people or groups of people I'm
not sure yeah I think Jaeger in a German
means hunter I believe yeah I think
that's what it is because it's like
vampires and crap killing each other I
don't know looks gory I love that [ __ ]
yeah never been done before
well this doesn't look like that's the
main premise of the story like if if you
read the synopsis and if you watch some
of the previews like it looks really
good um we had someone in a caster for
life says he wants to see our three on
the list already good luck man
good luck with the sequel that we have
no news on brick you look weird after it
was announced yeah I remember talking
about that the last time I was here no
like it's been over a year and a half
since they announced that they've since
had to recap films which by the way went
off the original like plot so the
emerges recap films they change stuff
from the original and now the rumor is
that the sequel if it ever happens it's
going to be an alternate timeline which
is cop-out and [ __ ] yang while but
I've been waiting for some real news
about the actual sequel so I can make a
video talking about it but we've had no
real news all we've had is them selling
merch on the website so I don't know
thank you God Church um also who is AK
Harry says tell Briggs I love him
let me titted let me tip what if it's a
girl love you to you sis let me to say
there's also many horror fans out there
like Roman Ivan brothah like Brodus s
but the bad joke
oh yeah this is this is the enemy
codename bro that's just serious oh yeah
that's it's a set suit how the hell do
you say that SATs our SATs aruki sat sri
KU sat sri Kuno 10/10 she 10g I think
I'm only reading the ones of eg names
that's right on the second row on my
enemy list it's the first one in the
second row sad surah Kuno Tenchi ha I
think I got that correct
I feel confident on what I just said
that looks like a very interesting one
kind of searching like a coral Ally your
own little Porter lolly come on there's
zero chance out of mouth watching this
so good good let me try no markup liars
and stuff like this he's from Ohio
he's probably into it man it's probably
yeah I wouldn't doubt it no but just you
guys know nala is a big fan of horror
anime it's good because I don't really
watch much horror so it's cool that
she's got a gear telling us what she's
excited about I've seen some people in
the chat are more grand blue anything
else in the chat guys that you're
specifically excited about I think I'm
gonna watch granblue it's a comedy
actually slice of life which is nowhere
near my like cup of tea but like just
reading the synopsis it's about like
like college students and like I'm so
used to high school students like just
hearing about college students I'm
already interested and it has water like
granny Grand Line yeah oh okay now I'm
gonna watch it just cuz no I'll give it
a shot I will I'll give anything a shot
I always give everything five episodes
if I don't like it after five I throw it
out yeah yeah college students as well
like it tends to be the anime that kind
of like push the envelope by focusing on
older characters tend to end up being
good because they're more unique I'm
curious to see that as well just to read
the description real quick it's like
this so this guy I don't remember his
name
keep Tahari Laurie whatever I suck he
will be moving to his uncle's draw
diving store
granblue there he finds the beautiful
ocean beautiful women and men that love
diving in alcohol like I'm Kanna sold
I'm sold
Spring Break I'm sold yeah it's like you
know how a lot of anime how like the
beach episode yeah this sounds like the
beach this is awesome this is what we've
all been waiting for
right no okay it might be real quick I'm
starting oh wait um the one that I was
talking about though like you said oh
this looks like kind of like a harem it
was a how did not summon a demon lord
but they used a very crazy long Japanese
name that I'm not going to use that one
kind of reminds me of like monster
Musume meets devil is a part-timer is
that lovely
after all is a looking guy yeah and this
is 2018 up there summer and has to go
inside one's a cat girl yes so this is
another yokai lolly video game thing
yeah
the title is e sekai mouth or show
control Jodi budgets in English that is
how does how to not summon a demon lord
which is weird because yeah I definitely
see it kind of demon lord there mafia
devils a part-timer and then we have the
whole MMORPG aspect he's a really good
gamer and then he is transported to
world where he is the character from the
game like you're just combining it all
it it's one of those and so it's like
Overlord means the devil is a part-timer
with lollies yeah yeah yeah but I can't
wait but Necco this is one of those that
recon would be super excited for it was
here
oh no recon would be very excited for
this this is when we need him because
I'm kind of excited just for the fact
that that just sounds entertaining to me
okay I need to read this description for
you guys it's called the Backstreet
Girls a group of three authors assailed
their boss for the last time after
messing up an important job the boss
gave them two choices
honorably come honorably commit suicide
or go to Thailand to get sex
reassignment surgery in order to become
female idols what the [ __ ] Oh after a
gruesome year training to become idols
they successfully did you with
overwhelming popularity much to their
dismay this is where their tragedy truly
because that looks good I'm sorry but
that sounds [ __ ] hilarious that does
sound pretty funny sometimes seppuku is
the right choice
yeah probably was but then there
wouldn't have been an anime yeah really
weird
there's another one that looks like
[ __ ] sword art online chakuda
no-ho-ho so say who know about Korea oh
that does it looks exactly like [ __ ]
sword art online they all have swords
well just call it the Valkyrie enemy
it's literally sort of like it looks
like for online literally oh by the way
if Jojo was here you would be telling us
about free dive to the future which he
loves free I actually like the first
you've never given three a chance
because why would I when I can watch K
Joe but a lot of people say that free is
the cool sports atom and they appreciate
it all looks really cute
yo it's cyanide blizzard in the chat or
is it the real one Oh check that play
Street Fighter okay high score girl
looks like a good one
it looks like a cute romance what what
are you excited for man also
cyanide apparently translated another
cone a super game that looks fun fun so
that's that's cool and Connor super
movie has been announced but
guys that's gonna be cool like I like
you I'm like that was remembered last
year there was like an announcement of a
new kind of super project there not to
be a movie and which is cool hopefully
the movie successful will get another
whole season because I like that anime
it's like one of those anime that's like
funny entertaining thought you ought to
think too much but it has best girl
which is darkness
so I mean I'm not gonna disagree
like I like mega mean but I think I'm
more on the darkness side
finally when Knox was here you were more
woman than I am inside but I think you
you've I just realized no I don't think
I was on mega mean sad I was saying like
she's funny but she thought like that's
girl I don't know she's not much from
Dustin know there's not much more to her
other than that exactly that's what I'm
saying she's just quirky that's her
whole thing she has no personality oh I
like it
I mean darkness is pretty quirky well as
well but in a good way
yeah but darkness his name is la latina
okay
there's another horror on here that I'm
sorry I'm finding more horror I can't
believe they're kind of like I was gonna
make a really long like intricate video
of like why there's a lack of horror
genre with an anime but now they're just
slowly it's like all of a sudden now
they're making more and now I'm like
what's happening is happening
yeah well video ASAP there have been
some failures recently that I've been
like anime or anime that have been
poorly received
Jun Jie eat oh man that was yeah at
least to me man that that was the
biggest letdown ever I didn't think they
were gonna freakin sugar coke baby candy
[ __ ] it so much I'm sorry yeah I know
like I know even super I pass both made
a whole video talking about disappointed
us and like yeah what I spin off of Chi
Chi the gambling anime or if he hasn't
watched it I just want to say the house
- I just want to say that before we get
into that that Josh Duffy is wrong in
the chat he said mega Mina's best girl
stop being wrong man just because you
put caps doesn't mean it's gonna make
him right Oh shame on you Josh
I mean it's a good strategy
shame on you shame on you and your Co
I guess til it's summer there's a bunch
of like Beach anime type thing like this
one takes Okinawa there's free there's
grand blue there's Island by the couple
of Studio feel which I've never even
heard of mmm I'll be interesting like
the promise a lot of these anime plots
would work just better as hentai you're
not wrong like you know they're all an
island and it's just a bunch of chicks
and then a dude comes yeah they do they
got a volleyball one to the Haru kana
receive they do got a lot of summer
stuff in here and of course we have
another season of freaking Gintama the
show that never ends yeah if uh yeah I
think everyone through this great but no
one's ever watched it yeah no Knox
actually has uh but now I'm watching
Jojo so you know you give me give me
give me some time to catch up to that
before he makes me watch $800 of Gintama
yeah I went hard on JoJo's but it's
pretty yet it is it's just one of those
things it's like yeah I mean it still
like is like one of those things like
popteen epic kind of like one of those
things or is it like one of those things
like shin-chan one of those things oh it
gets me and way more than it should but
like it I could see why but like it's
don't go into it thinking it's a meme
it's a good anime no it's like it's very
campy and over-the-top but it's still
you know as a story and so it's kind of
like kill a kill more than like some
kind of you know western old cartoon
Aussie Dragon Ball meets Death Note and
jojos it's super dramatic fighting with
like super like in-depth type of
analysis type of thing or like mind
battles within the fight it's pretty
cool especially if you get to the stands
I give five episodes oh I mean in the
first night are kind of met part one
it's alright
Pollyanna Miller says is anyone excited
about Dragon Ball Heroes yeah like that
animation coming on but it's not is it
coming on in the summer because I don't
see it on my enemy list I know it was
announced but I'm not sure when exactly
supposed to start airing I'm never gonna
watch it it's like an economy based on
the variable hero's game so it's not
like Canon but it's just gonna be like
oh my god they're bringing fucking's I'm
sorry I'm not meaning to curse so much
they're bringing Zoids back
they're bringing I don't know that is
there's a bunch of stuff that looks like
Digimon and [ __ ] no they're like it's
like um it's like Gundam but they're
animals okay Boyd's wild guys Lee yes it
is well it was me I mean there is no
description though like there's a lot of
stuff like future cards shin bunny fight
that looks like some kind of Digimon
shadow that bringing back Zoid that's
cool that's my that's my childhood man
just so you guys know usually the big
seasons for anime are spring and fall
right so summer and winter are usually
the not the most hyped anime so well
there is some really hype ones like for
example it's a complaint in so forth so
forth seriously and stuff like that
there is some you know you know not as
high budget Beach anime harems you know
that's just happens in the summer anyone
else in chat something some of the
anyway you want to really talk about
that you're super excited for and can't
wait dude my mind is blown right now you
know that anime that you've said with a
sword art like sword art online ripoff
yeah and then lastly there are q season
ago there was like a smartphone anime
yeah they combined it look at this he's
like when he uses his phone our fine
what are you reading which one um
chakuda in Ohio's I'm not reading that
anymore
EMTs the one you're talking with that
literally looks like her online and we
brushed it off like yeah litter its they
added a smartphone what are they doing
okay go ahead you could read
if you want go ahead yeah so it's so
it's combining Norse mythology Easter
Kai with some artful funds this [ __ ]
like like picture like pitching that to
someone like yeah do this
there was this cool anime that one like
we got super popular store online let's
combine that with the smartphone anime
it make it super generic and like yeah
let's play the character have a cool
black sword and dressed in black kind of
the new black swordsman yeah and it's
like hey wasn't the smart fireman just a
copy of Sora already it's like yeah yeah
but now we're combining and it wasn't
doing his no threat
the entire enemy I actually watched it
for whatever reasons yeah I don't know
why but I washed it it's kind of I guess
I went to the very end and I'm like okay
cloud at all but there was no threat the
entire anime and the side characters
were very bland but like the guy was his
overpowered he was curious though times
10 with a smartphone yeah I was
solar-powered I so I even the first two
episodes it was like oh I have all the
powers yeah I just got worse Oh yet even
more of all the powers there's a someone
like a child was mentioning terraformers
but I don't see that here also we have
era terraformers something called
phantom in the Twilight supernatural
vampire genre set in modern-day London
the story takes place in a world where
shadows are born from human fear and
anxiety so basically in modern society
were all [ __ ] because everyone's just
afraid and anxious about everything um a
young girl arrives to study abroad only
to be caught in a bizarre incident as
she enters University Oh more
universities do anything okay my city
with no one Queen it says the hopeless
girl wanders into cafe forbidden a
mysterious cafe that exclusively opens
at midnight which one is that again good
hentai plot what's that called phantom
in the Twilight
the toilet meets an assortment of
handsome men employed at the cafe where
a Guardians who protect the boundary
between humans and shadows could mean ok
well if it's a reverse harem I'm not
watching yeah yeah I'm not I'm like
totally bored with harems now yeah I am
so confused
there are good harems like oh man but
you have to do it right or even like
Angel Beats to an extent would be a hair
right well like you have to do it right
like yeah the individual girl characters
should all be interesting and on their
own not just depending on what the main
character think of things of them and
that's the problem with anime like sword
art online and the other mainstream
harem crap you don't care about any of
the girl characters that's a good
example of like oh no surah so success
successful they have a good cast overall
not just like the main character plus
like basic side people which one aqua no
Suba like darkness mega mean aqua yes
and also with kana supa they make fun of
the whole harem genre yeah so they're
not all just obsessed with with Cosmo
Monaco we just want to be with you if
they're kind of like mad it's it they
have like a kind of like a love-hate
relationship it's like they're like
friends you know like exactly would be
like the job at each other and stuff
like that which is why it's cool and
then they have that side character who
is the traditional harem protagonists
right like the guy that's really skilled
with the sword and stuff yeah and then
like all the girls level
yeah like huh well like that's why I
could assume as good as just it's kind
of like flips it around a bit and makes
it more interesting as opposed to like
anime that are straight-up embracing the
cliches I feel like if you add good
comedy as well to a harem like I feel
like the reason why I like monster
Musume did so well because like that was
a very cliche anime but there there was
parts where there was really really good
parts of comedy like really good parts
of comedy and I think that's the reason
why that did so well was you know as
well you can't just have one good
character or like the attack on Titan or
like slice-of-life example you gave
before like if
watch like slice-of-life is you're only
interested in character-driven stuff
like ice one at all I want a good story
and good characters you know well that
is the ideal all I'm not even say any
time 100 characters are bad eyes like
personally don't feel attached to them
as much yeah but you're wrong
my mind is blown right now by the way
guys I don't know if you want to scroll
to the bottom
it's like third from the bottom Marvel
future Avengers second season by
madhouse studios what is a movie where
it's like a third from the bottom but
like in under TV like I know them like
main series okay that's like what I'm
seeing right now like somehow you could
like change the order by like going
alphabetical or whatever I'm sort by
popularity right now why would you do
that so what is the least popular by the
way okay I see terraformers now it's an
OVA that's coming out so it's at the
bottom terraformers OVA let's say if you
see something Marvel they def and only
just have to watch it like I'm forcible
like I'm forced to watch it
yellow how is it that Batman movie
that's coming out that's DC no it's
literally Marvel it's got Hulk Thor Iron
Man very looking guy in the back we'll
find it
we just gotta we gotta use the power
okay you know I'll sort by um I don't
see where you're searching is top at the
very top Oh short right there okay sort
by while you do that seven of these
things got up is getting a movie August
18th oh yeah we yeah I'm hype when is oh
is the movie just kind of like filler
like outside of manga stuff
yeah it doesn't long of stuff I really
wanted it to be the vampires of Endon
burg which was the first introduction of
askin or I thought that'd have been a
great movie or they even a great like
ova special type of thing yeah that's a
manga spin-off right yeah come on
extra exactly it's a special order
type of thing but there seems to be
completely separate like original okay
we'll see ya well I'm excited either way
there's also one oh yeah that I see here
that looks very edgy just a bunch of
different chicks on a bed showing their
asses but there's no analysis and it's
like a one episode of Yates called Ian a
cow sudden I got up on sue me said to
Mordecai
like yeah it'll be a mess let's make it
a hentai isn't the title like you know
it's gonna be can we all complain about
the fact that when you find a bit hentai
it's only two episodes like why well
that's why I said I'm actually a good
storyline in the hentai and you're like
why is this happening
yeah like what I just highschool DxD
again like 800 episodes but we can't get
a decent hentai with more than two
episodes guys that's funny
haha a happy sugar life that looks like
a good one that looks like a horror but
it looks like a horror that a lot of
people could get into because it's also
a romance as well I'm kind of expecting
expecting expecting a yandere in the
myths
possibly oh it's horror mystery
psychological yeah I guess yeah I could
see yandere being in there yeah
especially if you read the synopsis it's
kind of like about love so blah that
makes me very excited yeah so excited
I've been talking to chat about black
clover is it still continuing oh yeah I
was gone again for like 50 episodes on
really 54 episodes so probably it's
gotta be continuing pretty much
throughout the year yeah okay I actually
really enjoyed the black clover manga
I'm so upset like who do parent sucks
they actually sucked it I've personally
watched like the first 20-something
herbs of the book where I don't mind it
but I'm not caught off blocking it like
maybe if I watch now like all at once it
won't be as bad but watching a week by
week was actually torture yeah I can't
like I know a lot of people were saying
it sucks but I was like yeah that's fine
it's like classic Shonen yeah
type animates me like I think it could
have been a lot more popular and like
potential to make videos on the type of
thing if it had a good anime or
faster-paced
oh yeah now yeah yeah most definitely
but I think most people watch the first
couple episodes and then it's kind of
like fell off especially with that
annoying voice oh man that was hard for
me that's what I couldn't 2nd episode
I'm like nope can't do it I literally
can't it gives me a headache read the
manga you don't have to listen to [ __ ]
like you still sitting I might know I'm
thinking about reading the manga I have
then cuz I'm like dude I'm all caught up
in one piece I might as well know you
have heard good things about the black
hole hologram it definitely has
potential and like I said in terms of
the anime I don't mind it as much as
people like yeah you just haven't read
the manga I feel like what I liked was
it looks like it was fight after fight
after fight oh so fast-paced and then I
go to the anime it's like [ __ ] is taking
forever like they're like literally
adapting a chapter per episode or like
they're like on one piece standards yeah
because what they did was it's not that
long or longer yet and yet they got 50
episodes as opposed to for example
Balkan or hero which does 25 episodes I
would have much rather than have 20
episode 24 or whatever and just do a
good job yeah so for example with boku
no hero it's not airing all year I'm
sure there's people who would love it to
arrow a year like general super did and
like one piece does I don't I don't I
like how they're doing it now yeah yeah
but the way they're doing it now is
they're adapting in a way where there's
25 episodes per year but then you know
don't have one episode or two that are
kind of filler or whatever but most of
it is canon and paced probably they
don't stretch things out the fights are
not stretched out so it's like I love
that sense it works
it's just that yeah you're not gonna
have it all year Rob its quality or
quantity you know yeah most definitely I
agree with that another one that looks
really interesting on there look at it
it's called on gold Moi's gang cool cos
inky and it says the description says
the scary Great King comes from the
other side of the seed the biggest
incident gang coup that shook medieval
Japan is being drawn in an original way
in this historical anime along with the
beginning of the samurai hmm
so a historical item about samurai and
Japan medieval Japan to me that is
definitely interesting sounds awesome
big fan of history Japanese history
samurai on that just saying that taught
me thinking about wanna good Ceglie oh
my god okay in want oh this is so crazy
I can't wait I'm sorry I'm at I just had
to do it my mind exploded I'm like he's
gonna still be airing in the summer yet
yeah one has never ends so I guess
finally you're allowed to bring it up
it's enough blood for us true and I'm
not to be proud of me for that segue but
basically wanna know Kingdom is gonna is
like based off of like Japan or what's
it called like the samurai samurai
something I thought like yeah I'd do
something with samurais yeah just like
the the age of samurai in Japan I'm can
can't remember the era or whatever it's
called the Shogunate there'll maybe
probably cuz there's a struggle yeah
whatever it's based off of that or
something like that and I'm excited kids
to be swords and fighting and so dude
this I feel like we're about to get like
a crazy background is aura like we did
was yeah I hope so he deserves I think
you've got the leafy exactly well or oh
is that he is a Mexican folk hero yeah
that's gonna be that's gonna be your big
reveal but uh-oh some people that try to
be talked about one punch man season two
and yeah that's an interesting thing
it's definitely not in the summer but
we've had like three different occasions
on which it was confirmed that one punch
man season 2 is on its way but each time
that we've gotten the news we haven't
gotten any release date information so
we were news saying one portray season 2
is being produced one punch man season 2
is coming one punch man season 2 coming
soon but like we haven't done any
release date so we've been getting the
same information same news and people
keep getting excited about it that
there's coming but we already know it's
supposedly in production yeah it's
already been in production supposedly
for over a year
not everything at a four-episode
masterpiece like that's the thing I
liked you if I'm gonna report something
or like talking about something I like
to release it because until then
Indiana industry unless you own the
release date you never know what's
really happening and for a season do for
all the reports that it's coming soon
and I hope it is maybe fall or something
or from winter but there's still nothing
confirmed yet from from what I know
honestly I think that at this point they
could probably totally dick with the
audience for like fun and people would
still be like intensely ready to watch
it like I wouldn't be surprised if they
gave us like one teaser episode sometime
this summer and then gave us the full
season next summer yeah that would suck
though yeah but the thing is because one
punch man is a meme anime anyway they
can totally [ __ ] with the fans yeah they
might not really say they might say that
they're not going really sitting there
canceling it and then release it on
April Fool's Wow that'll be more of a
judges I'd be amazing on George's par-5
got uh did he get a date or just like
confirmed to be released or like in
production oke Tober is what I heard ooh
sweet I can't wait until fall I'm sorry
for the fall season but our family
JoJo's part five in October and it got
announced right after I started watching
it so you know you're well know the best
horror and comes out by the way you're
waiting and then finally axed I wasn't
dodos and they're like an out there
announced par five so coincidence
I don't know what I'm so excited that
there's more variety for me starting to
grow out there and bananafish just looks
really good I'm really excited for I
know I keep going back on that but
that's I think I think that's the one
I'm most excited for
okay well I look forward to actually
hearing from you if any of these horror
anime them and are coming out are gonna
be any good you're excited for it Bob
we'll see if any of them are actually
worth it so you'll be the tester yeah
yeah yes sir you're the one that's gonna
watch them anime be like is any of these
actually worth it I'll do a review on
the channel because once I move I'm
getting the whole studio and everything
that's like one of the reasons why we're
moving it so I can have an office in a
studio so I have all that nice is Dragon
Ball Heroes going to have guys because
is it like oh yeah like why is that the
hottest right along here oh I think I'm
not in the loop what's going on it's a
series based on a dragon ball game that
pits like all the Opie characters that
are not even cannon against each other
yeah like they have characters I guess
that only appeared in the manga also as
well from like the 80s
the games at UT they talk I seen
actually commercials for um through ads
I think on Twitter your Toonami
because they're doing like a series for
it I think they're already English
dubbing it oh that's pretty cool I'm
excited even though you know it's so sad
I didn't even finish to turn into pop
turn him into power that was I was like
heart what are you thinking I think I'm
like like eight episodes it's like
behind well at least now you can binge
them right it was hard way
week after week that was torture I think
I caught up and Anais forgot about it I
really was actually good art I don't
know how how have I not seen it I love
dragon law
I love how Angelo and the child is like
an America long-haired yeah it's been
happening been happening didn't happen
overnight but another one that I see
that looks interesting it looks more
like a thriller than a [ __ ] no but this
yeah augu tents same in you a seared the
series is about a missing Jean
whose mysterious disappearance becomes
the shady secret among us among the
successful members of society mmm that
does sound good
that sounds like it's one of those that
has potential right it could totally be
screwed up but yeah ya know it sounds
like I have something applaud trip be
clear exactly I love that stuff no it's
not I think I'm the most looking forward
to backstreet girls it could be really
funny I know I am - that's so ridiculous
I'm so you guys watch something let me
know if it's worth it yeah well I you
know cuz I don't want to get into that
like this was the biggest waste of time
since boku no pico um some stuff yeah I
bet there's some something called
Cinderella girls third season another
digi bra anime did you load that [ __ ]
but I have no idea what that is I like
drama in school life you just you just
know you just know that someone's gonna
comment on this right off a no one
talked about Cinderella girls you
[ __ ] plebs oh my god construction of
the moai's show ever since Madoka Magica
and that was actually I was actually
very surprised about that series that
was good no I know but I'm just saying
cliche statements oh yeah yeah what is
this
this Dropkick anime jet jazzing chan
jezik and dropkick this looks insane do
that the soccer one is slapstick comedy
about delusional gothic gothic lolita
who summons a demon girl with a tail of
a Cobra no live together it's about a
girl
goth loli and a freaking snake chick
living together okay so it's another
freaking drug invade no but no it has my
attention because the dragon may drip
off
it sounds like insanity that's what
I feel like you sports on MSE Batman
Tennessee volleyball I see soccer yeah
Horo Cana receiver or whatever it was
where is the captain tsubasa is like I
left over from the last season actually
my bad but then there's yeah Hannah Bato
I think it's a badminton listen to me
Briggs what on this channel we say
football not [ __ ] soccer okay
American football is the only football
that matters so we say soccer and then
it's football living Canada Hannah Mac
yeah Canada says football oh really
where you're from Italy because what
does Toronto FC stand for Adam PFC stand
for bro nothing
oh yeah what is it that's for football
club [ __ ] but no one's a [ __ ] but wait
you say football for soccer no we say
soccer but American we say soccer we
kick the feet Oh life's like it's
kickball you plebs I like that good
stuff anything else that we need to talk
about before we wrap it up cuz I got
some important stuff to do guys I'm
hungry
I'm just not going to I think we've gone
through like almost everything yeah we
pretty much day let's see what we missed
I am - I'm trying to really click but I
can't very skinny husky behind you oh
yeah hey it was the one who jumped on me
earlier and knocked out the thing so you
guys could hear yourselves hermit and
almost sent everything tumbling down
this is great well clearly this this is
the best part of the whole stream is
just that husky chill in there oh my
gosh do you want to be the star of the
show yeah Debbie the stylo Huskies
they're all yeah what else did we need
to cover in this
there's usually like I said summer suit
you know is that there's gonna be a lot
of good horror I know the chat isn't
used to this because of the chats mostly
used to shown in I know all you guys
like attack on Titan there's a lot of
good horror coming you might get a
yandere who knows if it's good but be
excited they don't all like attack on
Titan some of them were shit-talking and
even adult should like it well whoever
[ __ ] stalks attack on Titan no bad shame
on you exactly exactly yes so I am
looking forward to
Gnawa checking out the horror anime
letting us know there's anything good -
Briggs checking out the guys forced into
a sex change to become idols yes let us
see that being so funny happen I can
also see that sucking triggering people
hard yeah
triggering people hard I'm gonna watch
this a nice little a chief sports
volleyball beach volleyball out of it
I'm not like Kade row has made all these
like other sports anime up with edgy
superfluous well I mean is a chi sports
yeah well you love it you love K Joe
right but like I love volleyball so much
I'm like volleyball and Adam a girl
that's like it can't go wrong well I
like volleyball and I also serve guys
like one of the best things in the world
of volleyball so I follow I really hate
it Briggs how you put everything and
like this perfect aspect like I look at
something like this looks like ass
you're like no volleyball anime girls
I'm like well [ __ ] I gotta watch it now
marketing class sales after all gotta I
don't know how to pitch it every single
time every single time I'm like man ok
now that sounds interesting yeah no I
mean like a lot of these I will not be
getting a chance to unless someone's
like I Briggs is like yo you have to
watch yet hina matsuri hina matsuri you
have to watch it like you have to watch
that HP volleyball one brawl it's great
and then I'll be like ok I'll check it
out but otherwise I just kind of I just
kind of wait for people to tell me ok
this is a must watch I don't I used to
like watch the first two episodes are
like almost
and then you know with hajimeta nogal
and all these anime I was like hey
you're a big-time youtuber now he's
doing at the time right arrow manga says
yeah that's true too like I don't have
done watch everything if I'm also gonna
try to make multiple videos a week
there's just no way yeah that's what it
comes down to honestly I had to put
everything on hold because I'm in the
middle of a move and I work a full-time
job right now so I couldn't the only
thing I can do right now is livestream
yeah and like exactly just you guys all
know how much time it is to put out like
multiple videos a week and you have to
keep up with the animator you're
covering and the manga and all the stops
like yeah like I watch animes still in
my free time but I can't watch 20
different anime at the same time there's
just no way Nick victory fire really
wants everyone to check out Yoona and
the haunted hot springs again animator
recut would love but Nick just really
wants to that's haunted so maybe Noah
watching my dog destroy a paper towel
behind my back right now and be bad
right now there's two of them destroying
it that's quite entertaining
yeah or nothing like just staring
because he's like the [ __ ] she knows
she knows why are you getting in the
trash dude she knows nuisance others to
say era manga sensei was lit MA which
gay cook would agree you cook is very
modern masterpiece every into era my guy
sensei and he doesn't take it well if
you insult this you know you're not
going out there
not to fire it up says hi q is the only
good volleyball anime haiku is amazing
have you seen it adamak since you like
volleyball no like you guys know I
haven't watched many sports anime only
like the ones that are like even though
IQ is one of those that's hyped up it's
like watch it so yeah we'll see honestly
the only three sports anime that I
strongly recommend Hajime no Ippo when
you're at boxing major which is baseball
my favorite baseball anime
and then I see which is volleyball and I
stole baseball I couldn't care less
about me because like eight seasons are
like seven seasons or something so I
think volleyball is the only sport I
could really get into because I like
that sport so much I feel like I used to
think the same thing but I started to
learn that it's like it's just like any
other anime you don't need to really be
like nice exactly right like if there's
a good characters and it's a good like
story like the sport like it's important
but it's not you don't need to like the
sport to enjoy it
yeah like figure skating is cool I'm
like I'm not gonna you know be super
into it and go to like rinks and watch
people be like yeah like I was like I'll
watch it on TV and like oh this is
interesting so I'm like I'm never be
that into it like I'm never gonna be in
there like World Cup ya know they're
skating at five I gotta get home to what
like though he's walking in this tight
windbreakers that can insulate it a
little bit of high waters you know
walking in all mad where is gone go team
you really cheer on a figure skater like
I guess you can be happy at the very end
great triple axel yeah you have like
fights in the stands between the fans
like quiet fights jobs quietly but
anyway yeah definitely a lot of hype for
a doc on Titan seems you don't that'll
be airing July 22nd so it's like a late
start it's weird but I'm definitely
super excited for it because I read the
manga and I know what's happening and
it's nuts
absolutely nuts so I'm super sad for
that and a bunch of other ones again
summer season is usually pretty chill
compared to the spring and fall season
but still some gems out there that I'm
looking forward to um yeah I think let's
say we can wrap it up now
Thank You Briggs and now for joining me
their links are in the description be
sure to check them out they're very cool
people Oh
or should I call Briggs Lord Abrego now
that's his thing mwah-ha-ha Lord riddle
the twitch the twitch Lord of yeah the
holy night of twitch no a primitive
Leona's which is amazing which is
amazing that's definitely my base
grounds I'm still gonna be doing YouTube
but that's my central station now yeah
twitch is so much fun but it's hard it's
a hard grind it's like starting fresh on
YouTube right yeah like we have a twitch
account for animal per but and we just
some some no stream I hang out in a
while just because Cozens been busy I'm
usually like to do it like the two of us
together just firing playing party game
stuff like that but I'm hoping over the
summer that we're gonna start doing it
more once a week twice a week just kind
of naturally because it's a more relaxed
atmosphere and you just kind of like
play games and chill without worrying
about YouTube stuff so yeah definitely
twitch I believe that it has huge
potential I'm like I want to be well
really successful just on twitch right
so it's funny things you guys had an
audience so like if you could like bring
some people over a little help you out a
lot like with getting started yeah that
is the plan eventually to kinda like not
only that like I'm pretty sure like at
least for me anyways one stream I make
the same amount one stream that I went
on YouTube in two years why donations
yeah donations bets I also got a game on
my twitch channel that people can gamble
their bits if they want to and stuff
like that oh I mean if it that up it's a
currency it's like a Bitcoin it's a like
twitch currencies oh yeah all my
donations have mainly been through a bit
some people are crazy with their
donations though yeah yeah most
definitely yeah that's cool I see that
that's the interesting thing because
with you know YouTube your de lying on
things like ads and YouTube's algorithm
but on twitch if
people support you and they want to
donate to you you get all that donation
so that's not it's a different approach
but definitely can work that's amazing
for building communities to like
especially if like artists and the art
community it's like it's just a way like
like if you're an anime that's a real
good way to connect with other people
there in anime and vice versa whatever
games or art you're in yeah yeah for
sure yeah all right guys thank everyone
in the chat for stopping by and hanging
out including Josh Duffy who was wrong
about best girl in Casula by the way
even though he's wrong he's still
imagined yeah he did but he's wrong
anyway as you guys know this podcast is
every Thursday at 5 p.m. Eastern Centre
time sometimes on this channel sometimes
on Knox tacos Channel and so yeah join
us next week and until next time see our
space gobble bang